if you got into a spaceship and traveled
long enough and fast enough could you
eventually loop back to where you
started assuming you don't accidentally
collide with another planet or star and
no black hole swallows you along the way
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the universe is a loop we
don't know much about the universe we
have no idea how big it is or where it
starts or ends for years scientists
thought the universe was flat like a
piece of paper and that if you kept
traveling in a straight line through
space you just sail off into infinity
but a new study of cosmic microwave
background or CMB might have just ruined
everything we thought we knew about the
universe and its shape what's in it for
you well if the universe is a loop it
would mean that a kind of time travel
might just be possible before we move on
to the time travel let's get the theory
out of the way I'll start with Albert
Einstein's theory of relativity Einstein
predicted that space could bend in
different ways meaning the universe
could be flat or curved or closed the
flat universe was the most likely shape
of all and by that I mean that it fit
our current understanding of physics but
then researchers found something strange
in the Cosmic Microwave Background
figuring out the shape of the universe
isn't an easy task
we've never sent a single space probe to
the outermost reaches of our universe
well we don't even have spacecraft that
could possibly go that far and this is
where the CMB comes in handy
the Cosmic Microwave Background its
microwave radiation that spread
throughout the universe a relic from its
very early ages because it's so old
CMB serves as the main source of data
about the universe and its past and by
measuring it
scientists can get all kinds of
cosmological information now this is the
Planck mission satellite it was sent to
measure temperatures in the CMB among
other tasks but the data that this
satellite brought back didn't quite add
up it suggested that gravity was bending
the CMB more than the researchers
expected and this isn't something that
existing physics can explain maybe we
were wrong about the shape of the
universe
maybe it's closed like one huge inflated
balloon there is a way to test this
theory although it's quite hypothetical
so put your helmet on and buckle up it's
gonna be a long ride
oh and by the way for this task you'd
have to not age for billions of years
you'd also need to build a spaceship
with warp drive technology equipped with
all that you'd begin your journey around
the universe don't say I didn't warn you
this one-way voyage would take you
billions of years if the universe is
much much larger than what we can
observe you might only get 1/3 of the
way but if the universe is a loop that's
less than 15 billion light-years in
diameter you might return to your
starting point that would be solid proof
that the universe is indeed a loop and
that physics as we understand it doesn't
apply
and what was I saying about time all
right Albert Einstein's suggested that
space and time are connected so if the
space of the universe is looped could
time be looped as well it might be the
universe could be repeating itself over
and over again from the Big Bang to the
Big Crunch that would explain how the
galaxies with their stars and planets
came into being and if we live in a
looped universe with looped time maybe
just maybe one of those young galaxies
you can see out there is actually an
infant version of the Milky Way that may
not be the kind of time travel you
expected the thing is the shape of the
universe wouldn't have any effect on you
or the earth or even the entire galaxy
but it might just give us a loophole in
covering the astronomical distances
involved in exploring the universe if
you really want to travel through time
it would take more than just a different
shape of the cosmos but that's a story
for another
[Music]
you